from The Epic Times Maine secretary says
voters May cast bouts for Trump without
knowing if it will
count I mean that's it right there the
the main superior court ordered that the
secretary of state has to wait for the
Supreme Court to respond as to whether
or not Trump can be removed before
taking him off so she says okay then
people may vote for him and if the
Supreme Court says he can be removed
their votes are disqualified despite
having already been cast that's not just
talking about removing Trump from the
ballot anymore they are talking about
retroactively removing votes for him now
understand what this means there are
many states Colorado whatever they've
lost it's like we want to remove Trump
no you can't do that if the Supreme
Court does rule that is up to the states
to decide maybe scotus doesn't come out
and say Trump can be removed they say
narrow ruling it is up to the states to
determine their elections have a nice
day Maine instantly then says all Trump
votes are here by disqualified Colorado
says all Trump votes are here by disqual
qualified and they can just do it they
are going to retroactively remove Trump
from the election but then the Florida
would would remove Biden Texas would
remove Biden and that would be pointless
like it would just Supreme Court can't
allow that it would be pointless in that
it would create pointless Federal we
wouldn't have a federation any correct
the Supreme Court kind of has no choice
but to uphold the constitution on this
and the Constitution says state
legislators decide how their elections
are run maybe the state congress is not
State not St Governor they already
allowed that to happen the past how
things run and if they run are different
stories you can't remove candidates and
say that that's actually happening legit
that's not a legitimate thing bro
they're protecting democracy bro it's I
mean don't know what they caner can't do
because there's a lot of stuff that I
would have said they can't do that
they've already done yeah you can't
infringe the right to keep in be arms
right no right man that one's been
infringed quite a bit yeah a lot DC it's
it's funny it's Federal jurisdiction of
all places to be Holden to be beholden
to the Constitution and you can't have
guns there yeah it's ridiculous it's
there is the Constitution is just a
piece of paper as long as people don't
believe in it and if the people don't
actually want to hold Joe Biden
accountable for
allowing the kind of illegal immigration
that that he's allowed then what's going
to happen is Governor Abbott will stand
up to the federal government as long as
he thinks he can the federal government
might actually do maybe there will be
violence and if the people don't support
the idea that the that Texas was right
the American people are not going to say
they're going to say no you were wrong
and blah BL blah but if the mo if the
majority of people say Texas is right it
doesn't matter what the feds think
because most people are going in the
court of public opinion that's what's
actually going to at the end of the day
matter the most but I don't think that
most people feel that way I think most
people are going to side with the
government because most people are
stupid say the government what do you
mean the tax federal government most
people don't even know what the
Constitution says let alone what the
laws are of what the Supreme Court can
and can't do that's the problem they
have no idea what is going on I mean
jenz I literally filmed a video of you
know what is the first what are the five
rights protected in the First Amendment
and they you they cannot tell you they
couldn't tell me what the Second
Amendment Third Amendment any of the
amendments were how many uh amendments
were in the Bill of Rights and that they
want to change the Constitution because
it's a living and breathing Constitution
so when it comes to an issue like this
in
it's not a living and breathing at all
but the problem of this in Maine is
Americans will not bat their eye and
they will think that this is legal and
that the federal government can do
whatever they want and sure you know
Trump's off the ballot what happens then
like people will fall for it and they
will think it's legal and okay when it's
not that sounds very blackpilled are you
do you find yourself without hope no
because I think there is hope I I think
there is if people continue to press in
and have conversations and you know
rebuke this kind of stuff because you
know if Maine does this I to your point
I think Texas should be like all right
we're removing Biden and same with
Florida and Fight Fire with Fire so you
do a lot of men men on the street stuff
right yeah and so I'm asking I want to
ask particularly about when you when you
ask people about um um when they say
they are uh voting
for H I'm kind my TR of thought here it
was about particular men men stre stuff
here I let see if I can remember it
pardon me like totally derailed it there
um but I totally forgot what I was going
to say pardon me guys my bad
right I love you we're just everyone's
going to remain totally silent for the
next several minutes figure out I will
say though about man on the street stuff
is like I I am I kid you not I have had
students tell me they want to take away
the Second Amendment entirely that US
citizens have no right to have an AR and
I'm like well what is that assault rifle
it's not an assault rifle it stands for
ArmaLite for everyone who doesn't know
that and and that's the craziest part oh
what are the five rights protected in
the First Amendment they can't even tell
me it's speech assembly petition relig
they have no idea the rights that they
have and that what we're doing is to
protect their rights and they would do
anything to get rid of them well my
response is you know if I talked to
somebody that said I want to get rid of
Second Amendment I'll be like okay
here's my idea you you want to live that
way deal so you don't get a First
Amendment you don't get a second
amendment and then I want to live my way
so I do get it all right why not all
right solution solved problem solved you
can live however you want to live go
live that way it's uh real important
that we teach kids about the
Constitution that's like
indoctrinating uh important they have
stopped doing that though that's so
shocking like that's the primary school
systems like primary function I would
think failed make people understand the
way the government works AB that is not
math in that collegate history classes
are focusing now more on critical race
Theory having race based history than
they are US History same thing you know
go back in middle school government
classes they're not teaching the basics
of our government
anymore most people don't know that the
federal government is not or that our
government is not a direct democracy
most most people don't know actually
like it's as basic as this most people
assume that they're not
free what I mean is most people assume
that they have to ask for permission to
do
things that's the general Assumption of
the average American and and when
someone something they don't like the
first thing they say is that can't be
legal he can't be allowed to do that you
hear it constantly constantly constantly
I used to see this word permit on street
signs when I was like nine and six I'd
see like doing this is permitted I'm
like well what does that word mean I'm
not allowed to do it cuz why would I
need a sign to tell me I'm allowed to do
something allowed to do
it that's how badly people understand or
how poorly people understand uh the the
very fundamental B basics of American
society you are free that means you
don't have to ask permission to do
and they don't even get that like
straight up the gut instinct from most
people is not that they're free it's
that they got to ask someone if they can
they're looking for
permission so if you're starting with
people don't even understand that
they're free then that means that the
rights that are protected in the
Constitution they don't conceptualize
themselves as already having they don't
believe they have the right to free to
to free expression they believe that the
government gives it to them they believe
they have to have permission that is a
fundamental
misunderstanding of what it means to be
an American and it is intentional that
people see things this way and the
evidence is in the
results I get like the idea that yeah
you can say God gave us our rights I get
it but like if you don't don't have guns
and a forc forcible strong border to
keep out idiots that are going to come
enslave you you don't have your rights
so you need to protect your rights with
ar Force of Arms but the concept that
you always had them anyway is kind of
like a tongue and cheek Ben Franklin
thing I get it you do have them it's
just they can be infringed so absolutely
you need vigilance and strength to to
defend your rights the Constitution
exists because the founding fathers knew
your inalienable god-given
could be infringed upon and so they said
okay government can't do this funny
thing is it's a piece of paper and you
know Michael mice points out that uh
it's it's it's effectively meaningless
people get mad about it but the reality
is we didn't have free speech the way we
know it today 50 years ago you couldn't
swear it was an obscenity you can get
arrested for swearing George Carlin got
arrested for a comedy routine where he
said swear words and so I mean that was
effectively a hate speech law the this
is what I call the left reactionary woke
is reactionary they like to say the
right is reactionary what reactionary
refers to is uh the French Revolution
you had the the left and the right the
reactionaries were people who didn't
want the fall of the monarchy they were
you know I guess traditionalists
rightwing so reactionary means typically
it typically refers to people who want
things to go back to the way they were
this is what the left is they want
race-based law pre Civil Rights era they
want obscenity laws free free speech
they want us to go back in time to the
1940s 1950s back to the way things used
to be except of course for like you know
women in the workplace that you know
it's not absolute but they're absolutely
reactionaries that pertains to race and
uh uh you know and and and other
policies like this so is that like we
have a new world order in this
internet-based economy and that we're
changing into whatever we want it to be
which it could be an American Republic
Bas Global Republic basically where we
have like localized government and but
then there there's there reaction to it
which is like no no no make sure it
stays communist and take away rights we
need to make it more amenable to
corporate governance we need to make
sure that you don't step out of line
with your corporate they don't want
decentralization they want
centralization you know that that guy
noval you what's his name Noah Harari
that's yval Noah Harari I just heard a
speech that he was doing um I guess from
Davos or whatever um and he's saying
things like you know that we don't
actually have
the right to we don't we don't have any
any rights at all they're all just
fictions and everything essentially that
Society does is a fiction it's all a
game that we essentially agree to play
that's what Society basically is we all
agree to play by kind of the same rules
and his argument that there are no
actual rights that
essentially there's nothing that you
have a right to at all uh it it actually
is true
because you know rights are just
Concepts that we create so if you don't
have any rights that are natural that's
what the government is for is to protect
individuals if it's not doing that then
it has no there's no there's no value in
having the government you know so it
doesn't matter if you if you want to
have a a um an international order or if
you want to have the I'm I'm totally
spacing on on my where my point was I
get it he did get it man it happens he
did it to me if he's saying that we're
just coffee today we're just playing a
game that Society is just a game of
where we're all kind of accepting this
then I I would counter with what when an
armed gunman walks into a room and guns
down six people were they all playing
that game no we need rights to protect
our ability to defend against that but
the the rights are the the thing that we
do create in order to protect against
that the rights are a are there a social
construct the game getting hijacked no
no against against a re the real death
that happens when someone comes in and
decides to not play the game because the
game is actually we get along we we all
you know manage to live together without
killing each other without resorting to
violence that's the game that's what
Society we talk a lot about civil
Authority at the world economic forum
and the world is that's half of the dime
like the other side is very gruesome and
you need to protect yourself that's
these World economic Forum dudes man we
used to have shared morality M it was it
was believed that we all recognized
certain things were right and certain
things were wrong most people did now
you have the woke with no moral
framework at all I mean this is it uh
Prager refers it what what does he call
it cut stem or what is it I always
forget this cut stem politics or
whatever that a flower is beautiful you
cut it from its root you can hold it in
the air and it looks beautiful then
eventually it dies mhm and what we are
dealing with right now is the far-left
ultr progressivists have been detached
from their roots for so long they are
withering yeah man there's this there's
this like I want to I want to impose
like morality on these people but until
you experience it and learn it for
yourself CU I I learned from like
soldiers I watch interviews with
soldiers that and it's like whether
you're watching a guy bleed out and die
whether he's your on your side or the
enemy side you're still watching this
human bleed out and die we have rules of
law of War to protect against melting
human skin off with chemical War weapons
technically until you witness it and
then you realize why we have those rules
what does that rule mean you don't want
someone to spend 20 hours melting
screaming like you prefer not to so we
we so by all means enter a war where you
say we're going to fight by the rules
and the other side says I will do
anything in my power to destroy you and
guess who wins hopefully the whole world
unifies against that idiot that will do
anything toe create some sort of
Civility but I think we've already seen
that in the US I mean the left has lost
their morality basis entirely like you
know they're okay with killing children
in the the womb they're okay with
calling out Republicans and hating our
election system and changing the
Constitution so where does their
morality lie if it's not more like they
are the immoral and so how do you teach
somebody something is immoral I don't
think that personally that they actually
are are concerned with morality I think
that they're concerned with you know
trying to undo the liberal order that we
that the United States has they're
concerned with power yeah the they want
control the yeah the point isn't you
know I I've talked about like my my
opinion is that that they are not they
don't believe in the enlightenment they
believe that like you can speak things
into existence that's why they refuse to
you know that's why they say oh if you
call a trans woman a woman she's
actually a woman or if if you call a
trans man a man they're actually a man
they believe that words have power they
don't believe that you can actually come
in contact with reality because
everybody's reality is different and
stuff and that's really foreign to the
to the foundational ideas that that
liberalism is based on you know you the
idea that you can come into contact with
with
reality is the foundation for what is a
reasonable person and the idea of a
reasonable person is all over our law
you look if you look at the way that
laws are written they constantly say
what a reasonable person would say that
you come to a reasonable there's no
reasonable people anymore yeah if you if
you can't agree on what a man or a woman
is if got supreme court justices that
refuse to ackn to to say what a woman is
that that will say I don't know what a
woman is or I can't Define a woman then
you can't expect that person to be able
to say what a reasonable person would
think and that literally this is this is
serious stuff this is actually tearing
at the foundations of all of our laws of
all of the structure of our whole
society the entire thing so when you're
talking about man people lack of
Morality In the government in the
federal momentum at the moment and that
you're you were suggesting that their
their focus is untethering or unwinding
the liberal economic order to create
this new world what I I see is the way
we unwind it is the New World Order so
if we use corruptive adaptivity if we're
willing to stomp out political opponents
unethically illegally to get this thing
that's what the new thing is going to be
it the method is the is the meaning
there the the ends do not justify the
means because you never meet the ends
the farle makes argument that the ends
justify the means they say there's an
evil dictator in charge so we must do
everything by any means necessary to
stop him congratulations how do you now
defend your glorious new Revolution by
any means necessary of course great
you're you're the dictator that that
that's literally the theme of will of
the people the song that we released
three years ago these people will claim
they're fighting for justice and so
their tactics are Justified there
diversity of tactics but don't worry
when we take over we're going to put in
a bunch of reforms to prevent the
brutality then once they take over they
say well yeah but we didn't mean for the
fascists they're fascists we're we're
the so the way Venezuela views it the
revolution's never ended the fascist
forces have always been trying to take
back and they're in desperate need of
defense of the Revolution that's why
they have to arrest people and lock them
up the revolution is always unending
it's the logic of Herbert Mar you have
to shut down fascists you can't let them
talk you have to you have to shut them
down at level of conception of fascist
ideas you have to to take control of the
language so that way you cannot form
fascist arguments well that's gone
Haywire with the Federal Reserve getting
formed obviously we are living in a
fascist system what about Communists
because people are are saying lately
like did the McCarthy era not go far
enough McCarthy era didn't McCarthy did
not go far enough I understand not
shutting down the concept of Communism
you need to understand it to watch out
for it to defeat it and circumvent it
you need to know what it is but which is
why we have redhed schools like you
don't hear about communism you don't
hear about the horrors of Communism
nearly as much as you should you there
should there has been significantly more
death due to communism because it was a
a system tried in so many different
places and has had has had a much longer
time that it was tried but as a system
it caused More Death than Nazism because
Nazis was you know everybody ganged up
on Nazism to stamp the Nazis out and yet
you hear more about Nazism everyone's
aware of of the Six Million Jews and
however many uh gypsies were killed and
all the all the the people that died in
the in the death camps in in Nazi
Germany very and people are aware that
there were Googs in in Soviet Russia and
they're aware that there was death in
China coming to China but they don't
know how bad and they don't know about
like the real horrible stuff that went
on in Eastern Europe like Eastern Europe
is where the real horror shows were when
it came to the deir that wasir was was
that one hore is that how you pronounce
it the Hol there's but there's also that
the marid has this has this podcast
about I forget what it's called but it's
about the horrors of a particular
communist group and I I'm totally
spacing on the name if the chat knows
I'm sure I'm sure the chat knows because
they know Mar's podcast but it was it
was about the things that that the
Communists did they were absolute
monsters and kids don't know this
because they didn't cameras like the way
that the Allies documented the Nazi
camps and the and Hitler kind of
documented his own behavior for the
world to see but like in in Soviet
Russia St was like a mute no knew what
sounded like no this is because of this
is because of people that believe in
socialism so they didn't report things
in the west it is an active intent to
cover up the horrors that's what redash
means yeah William Durant was covering
up the horrors that the Soviet Union was
doing Walter yeah Walter Durant there
there's been plenty of people that were
were Communists believed in communism
and then because of that they covered up
terrible things that Communists have
done because they call them excesses and
their their attempts that you know
attempts to to produce the perfect
Society I love how Durant actually was
like there's no need to actually
investigate whether any of these things
are actually happening
God newk you'd be shocked man it's wild
I kid you not there are students that
I've talked to that tell me Well
communism just hasn't been implemented
in the correct way yet or or or
socialism hasn't it's it you know Cuba
Venezuela whatever it's just it hasn't
been done perfectly yet you know if we
just listened and implemented socialism
and communist ideals like it could work
in America and like that's how far it's
gotten in campuses I remember my
question regarding uh you talking to
people on the street um when you speak
to people are they are they like do they
do they realize what is like how much
like people always say people on the man
the street things they only choose
certain people that say dumb things when
you do this do you chop very much
material to make it I don't not trying
to out your for for like what's the word
like uh unethical unethical journalism
but how many people do you meet that are
are informed that do know what's going
on versus how many people do you meet
that are like wow you're almost like a
lost cause like how many what's the
ratio to that CU that's that's what
really matters to me okay I will
honestly say gen Z is very 50/50 and it
also depends on the region what school
I'm going to so I just did a video and I
was at CLA in Beverly Hills OH 90% I
asked the question is America racist and
I had almost every single person tell me
yes America's racist systemically you
know you can't be racist against white
people like whatever it is but then I go
to a school like you know I went to
University of Arizona down in Tucson and
I asked just basic American based
questions and they could actually answer
American History questions so it's very
much it depends on what school it is
it's very very Regional um and a lot of
these kids are transplanter so you know
the kids go on UCLA are from all over
the place but they chose that school for
a purpose uh Socialism or communism or
capitalism I mean those videos are
across the board we do choose and use
almost every single one of the answers
we get so when you see any of my Clips
it's not because I picked that person
and that person I'm like oh that's going
to go the most viral I mean I'll talk to
our protesters and I'll talk to people
inside of our events and genuinely try
to get you know what is jenzie thinking
that's always my focus is you know I
want to show the world this is what gen
Z college students from across the world
or Across the Nation actually think
about these issues and it is pretty
split you know I was at UCLA and I had a
girl reach out to me and she was like
Hey like I was really scared to answer
your questions but I actually am a
conservative and I feel like I can't
speak out so there are kids on these
campuses that are educated and are
informed but the problem is is they're
facing so much censorship they're facing
cancel culture they're facing you know
their college campuses their professors
absolutely hate them in their ideals I
mean Harvard Free Speech doesn't even
exist at Harvard University anymore and
so these kids fear so much to speak out
I mean nursing students having to to
learn abortions and uh having to get you
know not going to say it but they're
having to bow down to these oligarchs
really that are controlling the
universities so they're so silent and
they're so scared I have an idea how
about uh the parallel economy forces
unify in a pledge to never hire from
this point forward anyone with a degree
from any of the major University Systems
only because I support a Road to
Redemption especially the UC system 100%
I'm goingon to say this yeah maybe like
for five years no CU everybody can
become I I don't even say for five years
I'm like we re we can reassess when we
reassess like if the UC system comes out
and says like you know Long Live America
and flies the American flag big and bold
and says now everyone's required to take
a Constitution test and all that stuff
I'd be like oh we're good but right now
I'm thinking about these people you're
bringing up a conservative what what
what college was she at UCLA UCLA yeah I
would never hire her and I think I I
think no company should hire her I think
if she ever steps foot in the building
and says here's my look I went to UCL
like get out like you mean to tell me
that you knew exactly what was going on
and you were like I'd love to have a
degree from this institution I mean that
that's that's like it if you're some
regular kid you got a degree and you're
like honestly I wasn't really following
politics I just wanted to do like you
know graphic design and stuff I'd be
like okay but if you're like oh I was a
conservative the whole time and I didn't
speak up but I wanted a degree from UCLA
I'll be like good luck getting a job in
Hollywood I wish you the best oh I mean
80% I would say honestly 70 80% of
college students that are conservative
on college campuses that aren't speaking
out they're exactly like that they are
just living their lives like I'll just
get through college you know I'll write
the paper all get the a and they are
willing to you
know who are you trying to impress the
Hollywood pet files no I mean like
you're going to UCLA to get a degree are
you you're trying to endear yourself to
the Hollywood pedophiles well I don't
want to hire you because their whole
thing is well then how do I get a job
you know if they don't get the degree
and they don't graduate and they don't
get the grades and they don't just like
silence themselves for four years then
where do they go and work well I I I
can't speak I can't speak foro out uh I
can't speak for uh jobs outside of media
I can tell you I have not asked about
anyone's college degree when when when
hiring here at timcast and we have 42
employees uh 42 a handful of contractors
so maybe like 37 or 38 but I've not once
been like and where did you graduate
college from oh no I agree I think they
should College doesn't matter in reality
it's a piece of paper it's so
meaningless where if you actually have a
craft and you decide you know I actually
instead want to do this we have the
world's knowledge on our finger tips you
can learn anything I just I don't see uh
like if you want to be a doctor or a
lawyer I mean I understand there are
certain things you have to go to college
War but of course if you're like this is
why I'm saying parallel economy uh I'm
not you don't you don't you don't need
any legal requirements to work at a
media company you need to be good at
what you do so if you come to me for
instance and say I'd like to work at
timcast and you're like I just recently
graduated from UCLA I'd be like I'm not
going to hire you who are you trying to
impress you're not trying to impress me
you want to impress me tell me you
dropped out of school and figured that
on your own look I got I got to be
honest it's not just about the the UC
system and these corrupt colleges it's
about in my experience somebody who
decides the path forward is to be told
what to do by institutionalized learning
facilities is not going to be as skilled
or driven as someone who figured it out
on their own they're not as critically
thought like the internet or the uh
college was good until about 1996 and
then the internet supplanted the the N
the nature like you said the the
information is now avilable unless you
can go to college for like a
conservatory if you want to study like
acting for for four years and you pay a
bunch of money so that you get like six
lead roles a year and you're surrounded
by good actors and you get really good
at it or music or something like that
that's a different story like you said
being a doctor you want to go somewhere
where you can do the practice every day
um well there's legal requirements there
I can understand that and you're not
trying and and if you're going to set up
your own practice or work for someone
else they expect you to have that people
that haven't figured it out that are
still going through the motions are not
critical thinkers not on the level that
you need to really get your business
ahead the hyperpolarization is too
pronounced at this point I mean when Joy
Reed I Love This Joy Reed was was
debating the mom one of one of the
people from moms for Liberty one of one
of the women and asked was asked about
adult objects appearing in books Joy
Reed defended children having access to
this but the joy read X account censored
the word because the general public
which is primarily
adults should not see this word but
children should when we're dealing with
someone like that okay when you go to
one of these major universities because
you think you need a
degree I don't know who you're trying to
impress cuz it ain't impressing me okay
now if you if you went to like some very
Christian University or whatever cuz
they exist or a private or one of these
newer ones they're anti-woke and you
explain I went here for this reason I'd
be I'd be like oh wow okay that's cool
um it's more valuable to me if someone
came to me and said I'm a video editor
and let's say I'm like I need a video
editor and they came to me and said
here's a bunch of stuff I've made I'd be
like wow this is really cool stuff can
you make more great you're hired there's
no circumstance where I'm like but hold
on I do like that video but where did
you go to school that make that make
that's completely meaningless tell me
about your parents before I hire you you
that's the problem with the college
degree system is because they graduate
college with absolutely zero experience
in the real world they don't have
critical thinking skills they don't know
how to think they because they've been
told their whole life what to think yes
that's the problem I'll give sh shout
out to Carter Banks our music producer I
don't even know if he went to school or
not he just made a video where he was
like hey hire me and then a few months
later I was like yo check out this video
and I was like oh wow this is a really
good video we should hire this guy yes
and then we did he will do more of that
and he certainly does so I think j z
should go and learn craft if you're
passionate about something go master
that craft be really really good at it
and then go do it thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 800m and become a member over
at timcast.net